how would you describe Nick's reaction
to seeing you in your custom Ralph
Lauren wedding dress for the first time
and cry that door open and I saw his
face and it's been nearly four months of
wedded bliss for Priyanka Chopra and
Nick Jonas on Thursdays watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen the actor
spilled some new deets on their lavish
wedding which Joe got you the better
gift Joe or Kevin well the good thing is
Kevin got us like hundreds of bottles of
wine and and Jill got us an amazing
fridge which looks like a car to put it
all in but then things got a little more
pg-13 okay do you believe in sexting or
FaceTime sex during long stints apart of
you Priyanka do you help Nick manscape
know what I did once
what just as fade back here okay later
the conversation shifted from Priyanka's
boo to her bestie Megan Markel the 36
year old actress cleared the air on the
status of their friendship they didn't
go to her baby shower because you were
pissed at her oh my god no it's not true
it's been a busy few months for the
brunette beauty not only did she have
multiple wedding ceremonies she also
promoted her latest film isn't it
romantic where she opened up to et about
what else her hubby and the romantic
gesture he pulled off the night before
their wedding
well that walked in my room with my
bridesmaids to do this like last night
then our separation and whatever and the
entire room was lit up and they were
like flowers everywhere making a pathway
to the bedroom and little gifts which
had notes attached to them with his
promises to me I will always keep you
safe I will always protect you I'll
always respect to you ever and like
everyone was and expounded on that not
just one and it was just like so
mind-blowing I think all my bridesmaids
were just sitting so depressed